c'est le premier entrepôt du nord de la
france du groupe à être équipée de
panneaux photovoltaïques l'installation
fournit aujourd'hui 10% de la
consommation du site le groupe metro
fournisseurs pour les professionnels de
la restauration équipe depuis 2019 les
auvents de ses entrepôts nous avons un
programme pour réduire d'ici 2030 notre
empreinte carbone de 60% ce programme il
était initié en 2014
2014 2021 nous avons réduit notre moins
de carbone de 31% donc on a fait plus de
la moitié il nourrit jusqu'en 2030 les
entrepôts de ce type seront bientôt
obligés d'installer ces panneaux
photovoltaïques c'est l'une des dix
mesures annoncées par barbara pompili
ministre de la transition écologique en
déplacement ce mercredi 3 novembre faut
dépasser les idées reçues montrer qu'on
peut le faire montrer aussi par
l'exemple de ce que fait cette
entreprise que c'est finalement simple
que ça apporte des solutions à tout le
monde et que on est dans une logique
vertueuse qu'il faut faire deux choses
pour y arriver la première c'est faire
des économies d'énergie donc faire de
l'efficacité énergétique isoler nos
bâtiments etc mais aussi qu'on doit
électrifié un certain nombre de de nos
de nos modes de production par exemple
dans les voitures qu'on passe des
voitures thermiques aux voitures
électriques mais ça ça veut dire qu'on
va avoir besoin de plus d'électricité
parmi les autres mesures mille projets
photovoltaïques sont prévus sur des
terrains publics d'ici 2025
l'accompagnement pour les développeurs
de projets et les collectivités ou
encore l'allègement des procédures
administratives pour les petits projets